This next demo will characterize
the effect of choosing to augment by
a shortest path.
We'll let M be a matching and we'll let
P be a shortest augmenting path for
M and then we'll let Q be an augmenting
path for M augmented by P.
Well, then the size of Q is at
least the size of P plus twice
the overlap between P and
Q in terms of the number of edges.
For the proof, we first observe
that the size M augmented by P and
augmented by Q minus the size of
the original matching M is equal to 2.
So the symmetric difference
between the augmented version and
the original, which is also equal to
the symmetric difference between P and
Q must contain two vertex-disjoint
augmenting paths of length at most P.
They couldn't be shorter than P.
Otherwise, P wouldn't
be as short as path.
Therefore, the total number of edges in
the symmetric difference between P and
Q is at least twice the size of P.
Now the size of Q plus the size
of P is the size of what is in
exactly one of the two plus twice
the size of what is in both.
You can think about the overlap
being counted once in P and
once in Q, but
not at all in the symmetric difference.
Well then, applying our bound on
the size of the symmetric difference
between P and Q.
We then have that this is at most,
twice the size of P + 2 times
the overlap of P and Q and
subtracting off the size of P from
both sides gives us the theorem.
A corollary of this lemma is that
if P and Q are the same size,
then they have to be vertex disjoint.
The fact that they are edge
disjoint follows directly from
this equation to argue that they
have to be vertex-disjoint,
we'll argue that sharing
a vertex implies sharing an edge.
So let's take this theorem and suppose
not, we'll let v be a shared vertex.
Well then, v has to be matched
in M augmented by P, so
Q must share the matched edge with P.
We can visualize this argument by
drawing P with the original matching M.
Then once we've augmented,
P becomes like so.
And regardless of what vertex
the path Q happened to share with it,
that vertex is now matched and
augmented by P.
So Q has to follow that edge, but
then Q and P share an edge and
Q is greater than P by at least two and
that then leads to a contradiction.